well hopefully you are watching this in
a territory that isn't going to explain
all this away as some kind of overly
elaborate joke or a perpetual cosplay
[Music]
hello everybody so today
i don't know how to
frame this context of my talking about
this other than saying it's
an issue with queer representation in
media and yeah we're going to talk about
it i'm going to talk about the erasure
of queerness
through localization the thing i'm going
to be talking about here is when a piece
of media is taken out of its original
context in its original location where
it was produced in the first place in
the audience that it was produced for
and then translates it for a different
audience and in the course of
translating also
localizes it to be
uh theoretically more appealing to the
people in that new place where they are
presenting it so obviously basically
anytime a piece of media gets
re-translated to another language this
is animes that get dubbed this is all
kinds of things it can be something as
minor as like a pop culture point of
reference because perhaps in the
original work there is a reference to a
piece of culture that it's not realistic
to expect that audiences in another part
of the world are even gonna know so the
translators and the localizers will find
a pop culture reference that is
equivalent but one that the new audience
would actually recognize and that sort
of thing so minor changes beyond just
translating the actual dialogue are very
common and often pretty innocuous they
can also sometimes be
hilarious like i remember when pokemon
first aired and they kept calling rice
balls donuts even though it was clearly
rice ball but anyways what i'm talking
about here is where localization
affects characters
and specifically when it takes a queer
character
and removes
their queerness
now part of the reason i'm using the
term queer is i am talking about this in
the broadest possible sense the entire
lgbtqia spectrum is affected by this
it's not specifically a gay issue it's
not specifically a trans issue it's not
specifically a gender identity or a
sexuality or anything issue it's across
the board and queer encompasses
everything so that's why i use the term
and i'm going to continue to use it
so if people still find that term
offensive
i'm sorry i'm going to keep using it
it's my identity and it works as an
umbrella term and it rolls off the
tongue a heck of a lot better than
saying lgbtqia plus every dang time
but in any case
it is not uncommon for
aspects of a character to be shaved off
because
it is either perceived that the audience
in the new territory that it's being
translated for won't be okay with that
or also it's possibly
some sort of moral judgment from
whatever entity has gotten the
distribution rights to do it in the new
country well maybe not a moral judgment
or they just fear that presenting it
will
result in moral judgment placed on them
as i've said in the past most of these
companies these corporations and in this
case we're usually talking about smaller
companies when we're talking about
redistributing these things as opposed
to something like disney or
warner brothers or what have you but you
know they're still largely motivated by
what they think is profitable not actual
moral judgments but i'm not gonna
completely rule it out because these are
as i said often slightly smaller
organizations and it's not impossible
for somebody in the pipeline be it the
localization director or just whoever's
doing the actual translation of the
dialogue to maybe make their own call on
changing something it's hard to pin down
exactly why in any specific case
so instead we're going to focus on the
examples of
when it happens and how it manifests and
i'm not going to delve too much into
trying to
theorize or extrapolate the reasons for
it because i'm not here to psychoanalyze
people who i don't know
um i'm not here to psychoanalyze people
i do know either it's none of my
business i'm not a i'm not a
psychiatrist
anyways
there is actually a specific instance
that spawned this somebody brought to my
attention on twitter that the character
of rain on the latest season of the owl
house which
people keep asking me have i seen it
i've seen part of it i'm i have disney
plus not the disney channel so i've only
seen the chunks they've put on disney
plus so far
but in any case rain is a non-binary
character it's a detail that doesn't
actually have a lot of attention drawn
to it
the character is simply referred to by
they them pronouns across the board
by everyone who is talking about them
and the actor in the role avi rock is
also non-binary he uses they them
pronouns so it's a
nice thing it's a nice character it's
well done it's well put forth it's
respectful
and evidently in the spanish translation
the pronouns were changed to he him
avi wrote spoke out about that and
expressed their disappointment in that
decision they were pretty diplomatic and
not like fully going on the attack about
it
which may be partially in the interest
of a career because you don't you only
want to create so much fuss especially
if you're not a massive name but
again that's speculative so i don't know
but
they did say this is really
disappointing
this translation fundamentally changes
the character
and it's a character that they
originated and so they're seeing
the character that they helped bring to
life that was reflective of a part of
their life that is not often
representative in media and now that is
gone
and there's a whole audience that will
never know
now they this particular thing might be
getting resolved in some ways i've seen
a couple of people say things like uh
that was a mistake they're fixing or
whatever but even if they do ultimately
that's a reaction to the change that did
happen now
if you've been on this channel for a
while
this might sound slightly familiar
because i kinda talked about it in a
more restricted sense particularly about
china
years ago now that particular
conversation was spawned off of the fact
that the film bohemian rhapsody was
released in china and china is notorious
for editing out any queer content and
bohemian rhapsody
how
well you cut about eight minutes and
just deal with the fact that certain
things now are completely unmotivated
like freddie mercury's breakup with his
female partner now is a completely
unmotivated thing but so what at least
the queerness is gone
so this sort of thing is
absolutely not uncommon and it was easy
to highlight with china because china is
a country where the government actually
controls
what gets brought in so it's not just a
matter of linking up with a localization
company who will translate it in and
distribute it you actually have to clear
government sensors there so it is a
slightly different ball of wax with
china but it is again still illustrative
of this remove
now so far the examples i've cited have
been of american products exported to
other countries and other languages that
have had queerness removed but um
happens a lot
for things being imported into this
country as well there was actually a
headline a couple years ago on a
re-translation done by netflix for
neogenesis evangelion because there was
a fair amount of queer coding between
two characters that the new translation
dialed
way
back and
fans weren't happy about it possibly the
most notorious example
is with sailor moon because in the
original the characters of sailor uranus
and sailor neptune
are a couple they are a lesbian couple
and when the work was translated into
english and broadcast in america
they were changed to cousins
but it was really weird because due to
the nature of the interactions between
these characters even if they removed
outright flirtatious dialogue there's
still a whole lot about their body
language and the way that they interact
that is clearly something that is an
affection that
cousins
shouldn't
have generally it's believed so
they they kind of made
the whole thing
very confusing because that was a case
where that was a fundamental truth of
these two characters and
while you could remove it you could not
remove every piece of evidence of it and
so it's still kind of there for people
to pick up and now the change you made
just makes it seem way weirder there are
honestly a lot of anime examples of this
kind of thing and probably more than i'm
really going to be able to cover since
i'm only slightly into anime but attack
on titan is another fairly recent
example where there is a character named
zoe hang i'm probably mispronouncing
that who is presented in a very mixed
way that does not clearly signify either
male or female and even when flatly
asked about it the creator of attack on
titan has said i think it's best for me
to not answer
that question and then later the creator
whose name i'm gonna put on the screen
because i would butcher the hell out of
it did actually go a step further and
managed to get the original publishers
to contact
the organizations that were translating
it into other languages to remove all
references to specific genders because a
lot of the english volumes of the manga
as it was being published
were actually picking a gender for the
character and they retroactively removed
that when they republished earlier
volumes and fixed it going forward so
that was a case where the creator
actually stepped in to try and address
it another incredibly frustrating
example is from a video game that i've
played and having played it i can see
exactly where all of the material was
supposed to be
but isn't and that is the character
vivian from paper mario the
thousand-year door in the original work
her sisters basically
harang her
for being manish
ugly
why do you dress like this i would say
she's a trans character she does refer
to herself as a sister of them but
all of these elements of the character
are removed in the english and also
german
translations
which meant that in the version of the
game that i played
there really is no apparent reason why
her sisters are mean to her
they just
are
because she's going to join your party
and if they're not mean to her she won't
do that but
it's completely unmotivated now
it's very easy to see where all these
details fit in that were
taken out and there's also some
incredibly messy examples where it's
actually hard to figure out the full
chicken and the egg and exactly where
what happened when and how and why with
characters like poison from final fight
or birdo again from mario franchise so
i've kind of talked about those before
because i had a conversation with laura
k dale about trans representation in
video games so if you're interested in a
more detailed look at those characters
and others you can check out that video
but my main point in talking about this
is to illustrate that this is a ongoing
persistent problem
for works both incoming and outgoing
and
it has not gone away as evidenced by
what has happened with the owl house
which is
a very very fresh product
and it's still happening
like things like the sailor moon it's
pretty well known and it's kind of
laughed about now but
we can't treat it like it's a problem
that went away
and i've talked before about why
representation is important and there's
something particularly insidious and
insulting about taking a piece of work
that offered representation to groups
that don't don't normally get it
and then taking it away before
presenting it to certain countries
now again i don't want to necessarily
pass
the idea that these companies are doing
moral adjustment judgments or actively
trying to manipulate sociological change
i don't i think they're making what they
believe is the best call
they are just wrong
i will say that i'll say that flatly
so the question becomes
what can we do
well really pretty much all we can do is
make a stink about it
which is something that fans have been
doing when they become aware of these
things and sometimes it can take a
little while because it requires a
fandom who can get access to the
original work in its original language
and also understands the new language
that was translated into well enough to
catch these differences because the
people porting it over are not going to
advertise what they've changed
so that's one thing and i think a lot of
fandoms especially in anime which has
become very very aware of this problem
in a lot of anime circles they do a good
job of raising a stink about it when it
happens
and that's kind of the only thing we can
do now when i say raise a stink i don't
necessarily mean boycotts but definitely
making it clear it's not okay
because these companies are making these
decisions based off what they think is
best for their bottom line but if the
intended fan base and the intended
market that they're bringing this to is
going you screwed up
it might give them pause
they might
do better next time
they might not then you have to raise a
stink again
but of course that's for stuff coming in
stuff going out when it's arrived in
another country and you're not actually
a member of the culture in that country
where it's gone to and it's been erased
that can be trickier to do anything
because well you're not the market so if
you are say an american fan of the owl
house making a huge stink about what's
going on in spanish-speaking territories
where you are not the intended audience
and they may well not care
may not matter much it may still be
worth doing to a certain amount in so
far as it may be able to through social
media spread etc bring it to the
intention of the intended audience that
they are missing a piece of the art that
has been removed for the version they
are consuming and maybe they will then
raise their own issues with it
but
you know there are issues with
getting overly um uppity about what's
going on
in other cultures when you're not a part
of it and or don't fully understand
where the differences lie
but it was worth pointing out what i
said about attack on titan and also owl
house
i think
it is
incumbent on the creators
of these original works
to bring uh to bring this up again
partially because that might make it
more likely to propagate and spread so
people understand what is being clamped
down on
and erased
and removed
and even if the motivation for raising a
stink is something as petty as
why are we not getting
the most complete version of this work
of this thing i like i want all of it
why'd you keep it from me and the
motivation is not actually the idea that
queer representation matters
that's okay because it still pushes
things in the same direction but one
other last thing that i do want to touch
on or rather remind you if you didn't go
back and watch the video that i made
about the issue of lgbtq
representation in things imported into
china then i should reiterate one of the
points that i made in that video
if queerness is going to be removed when
it gets localized anyway
then no company can use the excuse
that they can't put queer representation
in a piece of media
because other countries won't take it
yes they will they'll just remove it so
i don't hear it as much
i'm happy to say but i do still on
occasion hear the idea
that
the chinese market or other territories
where they won't be able to release a
film if it has queer content and that's
why what we can't have
queer representation in our marvel films
our star wars films our big tentpole
productions in general and it's bull
because these works are going to get
imported anyways
they're just going to have that content
removed
so there's no reason not to put it there
now that still creates its own problem
because it can result in representation
that is token and easily removed a
couple of scant lines of dialogue that
are easy to cut out without massively
affecting the story so you don't end up
with a bohemian rhapsody situation but
the fact that bohemian rhapsody got a
release in china means that
they are willing to take it out even
when it's thoroughly integrated into the
story so i would still say that's not
really a good excuse either but again
i've said in the past i would rather
have some form of representation even if
it's token and needs work it needs to be
better than to have none whatsoever
because if there's some representation
doesn't mean i'll be happy about it if
if it's bad or if it is overly token but
it's much easier to to work on and fix
and adjust and progress a thing that
exists
then something that isn't even there
getting the representation there at all
is a step we are still working on
and
the fact that sometimes that gets erased
when it gets moved to other countries or
gets brought over here
is
absolutely infuriating
and i kind of needed to get it off my
chest a bit
what are your thoughts on this
any other uh particularly juicy examples
you care to cite i'm sure there are many
i missed whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it
there's a bunch of other stuff to do
like share subscribe i have a patreon
that's how i pay my bills uh rewards for
every tier also there's youtube
memberships if you'd rather go that way
but um
i'm not going to put that much pressure
on you
because
at the end of the day
you are the council
i only run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
this video wouldn't have been possible
without the support of my patrons and i
want to give special thanks to jared
boyce
mj the doctor tracy scrabbit vincent
paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz edelon
robin moore ross schultz and shayla
gordon
thanks so much
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm
[Music]